la deuda es mortal el tema central de la
Cumbre de los 46 países menos
desarrollados del mundo fue el alivio
financiero para las naciones más
endeudadas el fondo monetario
internacional el Banco Mundial y el
banco de desarrollo chino son los
principales organismos prestamistas en
el mundo pero las altas tasas de
intereses de los dos primeros se
consideran abusivas el secretario
general de Naciones Unidas Antonio
Gutiérrez fue enfático al criticar a un
sistema financiero que deja los menos
desarrollados sin liquidez
es una cuestión de vida o muerte es
inaceptable que los frenen procesos y
decisiones que fueron tomadas fuera de
sus fronteras es una realidad que
nuestro sistema financiero global fue
diseñado por los países ricos en gran
medida para su beneficio
la crisis de deuda también ha sido un
tema en la mesa de otros foros mundiales
como el g20 entre los casos preocupantes
figuran Ucrania un país que ha tenido
que suspender el pago de su deuda
consecuencia de la guerra en su
territorio
necesita cubrir un déficit de más de 38
mil millones de dólares este año
Egipto un país afectado por el aumento
en los precios de la energía y los
alimentos ha experimentado una
devaluación en su moneda de casi 50% en
los últimos 12 meses sri lanka en medio
de una profunda crisis social y de
gobierno cayó el año pasado en
incumplimiento de su deuda internacional
por primera vez en su historia moderna
alcanzó un acuerdo provisional con el FM
y por 3.000 millones de dólares pero
enfrenta tensas negociaciones con China
India o Japón sus principales
prestamistas El Salvador enfrenta los
riesgos de haber adoptado el bitcoin
como moneda de curso legal cerrando las
puertas a cualquier posible
financiamiento del fmi
Naciones Unidas estima que 54 países
necesitan alivio inmediato para evitar
un aumento en la pobreza extrema hogar
de la mitad de la población más
empobrecida del mundo